this video is sponsored by nordvpn
why am i so tired it has to be one of
the most googled health questions there
is and i'm definitely guilty of
searching for answers like this myself
in the past
but the thing is i'm not tired anymore
and probably neither are you you
probably never were
it's probably not tiredness it's
probably lethargy the good news that's
easy to fix
[Music]
let's not argue semantics here perhaps
another term you could use is sluggish
the point is if you're coming home after
work you don't work a physical job
you're perfectly healthy you're getting
enough sleep and you're eating well
chances are that it's lethargy that
you're dealing with
and this is a big problem because like
i've said in the past your issue
probably isn't time if you can't work
out if you haven't started your business
yet if it was time you probably wouldn't
have watched all of those netflix
documentaries
and accusing people of being lazy is
just lazy nobody chooses to be lazy so
if you don't have the energy to do the
things you want to do at the end of the
day then it probably comes down to
lethargy you have the atp stores you
have the glycogen so what's really going
on here problem is if we put it down to
being tired then we assume there's
nothing we can do about it the only cure
for tiredness is to go to sleep right
but if it's lethargy if it's feeling
sluggish then there is something we can
do about
it chances are the problem is simply
that you haven't moved much in the last
several hours you probably went from
sitting in a car to sitting in a dingy
office with artificial light just
sitting on a train or in a car again and
then sitting on the sofa from there
you're then asking your body to get up
and perform when essentially is turned
off it has no reason to be awake and
alert that dingy light isn't helping
either it's put you into a kind of rest
and digest state likewise you're
probably eating lots of sugary snacks
throughout the day all of this has put
your body into a deep rest and digest
state your brain is probably awash with
inhibitory neurotransmitters like
melatonin and your limbs will have
practically gone to sleep this is
something called somatosensory amnesia
it's basically to do with your mind
muscle connection because you've been
sat on your butt for so long because you
haven't moved your arms or your legs
basically you've lost the connection and
now you feel weak and slow but any
wonder that when you get home you don't
feel like working out or working on the
next great novel
so you guys one way to increase your
energy levels is to nordvpn psych this
is actually the nordvpn sponsor segment
couldn't really think of a better way to
transition to that gracefully so norvpn
is a vpn that's a virtual private
network essentially what this is is it's
a service that provides you with servers
that you can use to redirect your
traffic basically instead of directly
browsing the web you browse via that
server using it as a kind of middleman
this way all those websites that you're
surfing don't get to see your ip address
they only see the ip address of the
server you're using this will allow you
to keep your information safe and
prevent a number of attacks but at the
same time it has the added bonus of
allowing you to essentially act as
though you're from a different country
because you can use a server based in
that location it does this without
slowing down your speeds because vpn is
the fastest vpn service that's just
confirmed by the latest speed tests it's
really easy to use it works on loads of
devices and bioneer viewers can get
access to an exclusive deal by going to
nordvpn.com forward slash the bioneer
and it's a 30 day money back guarantee
so it's completely risk free thanks once
again to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video
of course the trick is simply to start
moving again and this will get the blood
pumping this will reawaken your mind
muscle connection it'll spike the kind
of excitatory neurotransmitters that
will increase your energy levels
and the key is to convince yourself to
do a small amount of movement and
exercise that you're not going to balk
at now you can't try and trick yourself
here we're not doing a small amount of
exercise but really it's going to lead
into a bigger workout you can't trick
yourself just like you can't tickle
yourself so you have to be okay with
just a small amount of exercise but the
good news is that if this is all you do
it's way better than nothing so for
example you might want to do a little
bit of movement training or mobility
work perhaps some deep squats for
example
maybe you want to do a little bit of
work on your
hip mobility perhaps a little bit of
bird dog
the thing is if this is all you do
you're getting fantastic benefits you'll
be improving your mobility so that you
move better throughout the day if you
only had an hour to train per week you
could still get benefits if you split
this into 10 minute mobility routines
like this it could make a huge
difference the way you move and the way
you feel so you have more energy and
vigor throughout every day
of course if you can manage to do
multiple more intense workouts and space
them out throughout the day so you may
be doing three 30 or 20 minute workouts
this is going to be even better and i
talked about this recently in a separate
video where i discussed my best ever
results this will repeatedly increase
your heart rate increase your metabolism
spike protein synthesis increase
neurotransmitters in the brain and
improve circulation in general it's
going to keep waking you up throughout
the day so that you stay active and stay
in a far more productive state
obviously not everyone has the time or
the luxury to do that so you don't have
to go all the way in
at the very least implement some
incidental training this means training
throughout your day without making it
into a workout session per se so you
might do some squats whilst you're
brushing your teeth you might do some
club bell work whilst the kettle boils
or train your grip strength
of course a classic one is to install a
pull-up bar on your door frame and then
to do hangs or pull-ups every time you
go underneath
plus there are other things you can do
to wake yourself back up including
splashing water on your face getting
fresh air and exposing yourself to some
natural light so double points if you
take your movement outdoors
in honesty this has made a huge
difference to me as a parent of two i
now have more energy than i used to have
by the time i've started my working day
at nine o'clock i've usually been awake
for three hours at that point running
around the house with my daughter on my
shoulders dropping off at preschool and
that's not the half of it and yet come
the end of the day i still have more
energy for working out and working on my
projects than i ever used to have when i
was single when i was at university and
the difference is that i'm just moving
all the time now and ironically that
running around the house with my
daughter is actually contributing to
that giving me more energy now i need to
stay more awake one last tip that one of
my friends shared with me was that when
she gets home from work if she has
anything she wants to do that evening
she doesn't sit on the sofa at all until
she's done it because for her once
you've sat on the sofa it's game over of
course if you still find yourself
persistently struggling with tiredness
with lethargy then you might want to see
a doctor and discuss some other
potential issues like depression or
hypothyroidism the point is you
shouldn't always be tired it's not
normal and there's usually something
that can be done about it if you're
moving you're improving and anything is
better than nothing
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that would help me out immensely this
video was a little bit different today
because actually this week my family and
i we've all got covered so we're stuck
in the house most of us are feeling
pretty much fine my wife's cold is
pretty bad i've had a bit of a headache
so if you've been able to tell me
filming this one a little bit tricky but
i thought it was a creative challenge
and my wife and daughter helped me with
some of the camera work
[Music]
thank you that was really good you're a
good girl
so for example you might want so if you
hear some rustling and things in the
background that's what's going on there
let me know if you enjoyed the style of
video something a bit different i might
do more of them in future if this one
does well if you're interested in
optimizing your performance that means
improving every aspect of your strength
and speed and stamina and mobility focus
energy levels all at once then you might
like my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 and that also
comes with over two hours of video
tutorial including a follow-along
mobility routine that lasts about seven
to ten minutes i think you can do this
any day and it should give you an
increase in your energy levels and
provide tons of benefits in terms of
your functional movement either way
thank you so much for watching this one
guys and i'll see you next time
bye for now